your music and something happy so thank
you nate it was a happy site for us to
walk in the studio and see the flute
and what do we got going on at sherry's
house looks like it's a kitty cat
it's painting well you had an audience
nate
we had petey i had nala they were all
sitting here and just listening to you
they loved your otan involved
they were they were mesmerized they were
mesmerized nate
thank you by your charming flute and now
they've left the building
yeah now they're like oh music's over
we're out we're gonna go do something
else like ciao
maybe we'll get some food happy friday
everybody i think
petey's gonna climb in the christmas
tree now hopefully
you've got some warm plans for your
friday because it is cold outside i
don't know about you but i've been
listening to my palm trees and they're
just like
shaking all around flags are flying and
we've had gusty winds to
over 25 miles an hour in quite a few
neighborhoods sustained they're up
around 15 north las vegas and at the
airport
so it feels cold outside where you've
got those winds
temperatures are in the 40s for many
neighborhoods but
it feels colder than that i can
guarantee it all right so we had that
beautiful rain last night it was
brief but boy was it a welcome sight and
we also picked up
four inches of snow up at lee canyon
officially we picked up four
hundredths of an inch of rain as that
little band of showers moved through
clark county
it did take us out of that long long dry
spell of 240 days
the longest we've ever gone without
measurable rain
we'll look for a good sunshine today
upper 50s for highs
and again gusts 25 to 30 miles an hour
with those north winds gonna make it
feel extra cool
for our last friday of fall we've got a
good uh sunny weekend coming
and we'll start uh we'll start winter on
monday
65 degrees don't forget about the
christmas star that's jupiter
and saturn combining in the southwest
sky after sunset monday evening
breezy and cooler into the 50s again as
we head towards christmas it'll just
feel holiday-ish late next week
let's